an American the circus was familiar but
the circumstance unique he's been a
businessman a reality TV star and the
president but this was Donald Trump as
we've never seen him before as a
criminal defendant I never thought
anything like this
could happen in America never thought it
could happen
the only crime that I have committed is
to fearlessly defend our nation from
those who seek to destroy it this fake
case was brought only to interfere with
the upcoming 2024 election
and it should be dropped immediately in
the safe haven of his Mar-A-Lago home
Trump speaking publicly for the first
time since his arrest the audience and
assortment of family friends and his
most fervent supporters
to Cheers he repeated lies about the
2020 election they can't beat us at The
Ballot Box so they try and beat us
through the law
that's the country in which we live
however right now the USA is a mess and
with a very dark cloud
over our Beloved Country
I have no doubt nevertheless
that we will make America great again
this is Donald Trump trying to shape the
narrative trying to eke out some
political Advantage from legal strife
but these are the defining images from a
grimly historic day the 45th president
of the United States on an untrodden
path from the Oval Office now to the
courtroom dock
Donald Trump listened to the charges
against him speaking just nine words
among them not guilty
the world waited to hear detail of the
allegations they included cash for a
Trump Tower dormant relating to a child
born out of wedlock cash two for a woman
who claimed she'd had sex with the
president and that money for Stormy
Daniels the porn star paid off just days
before he won the 2016 election
this is the man who Trump claims led a
Witch Hunt Alvin Bragg the district
attorney bringing these charges to court
34 false statements
made to cover up other crimes
these are felony crimes in New York
state
no matter who you are
we cannot and will not normalize serious
criminal conduct
[Applause]
[Music]
now a subject of the Criminal Justice
System but once again center of
attention in time for his next
presidential campaign